[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
where's that for to think of it dear
John and Hank it's a comedy podcast in
which two brothers answer you questions
to beat abuse advice and worry about the
world a lot and then bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John Green
what is the elephant in the room
alright Hank let's do it three two one
ambient racism wait what ambient
inspired racism oh I mean I have done
such a good job of not knowing what's
happening with Roseanne other than she
doesn't have a television show anymore
and then you just you didn't let me
continue to live in that world I'm sorry
I'm sorry of course the thing we should
be talking about is Liverpool Football
Club John Liverpool had what can only be
termed an epic epic failure in the
Champions League final Hank it was
pretty brutal to watch as the goalkeeper
Laura scariest let in two of the worst
goals not just in the history of the
Champions League but in the history of
professional soccer just a proper
collapse and it was brutal to watch and
I have this is the part where I would
say the good part about it and the
hopeful part but instead all I feel is
despair
what's going on with Roseanne and ambien
please don't tell me well apparently so
basically ambien would like everyone to
know that and indeed tweeted about the
fact that the what none of the side
effects of their drugs is being racist
on Twitter oh that's good to know
yeah and because I do sometimes take
ambien yeah what up what happens do you
have any good design V and do stuff what
does ambien do it mostly makes me go to
sleep that's why I take it right do you
ever like wake up and you're like weird
story for me I wouldn't gardened in the
middle of the night or something no not
really no I took it after the Liverpool
Champions League loss actually just so
that I could get a good night's sleep
without having this too
horrific goals running through my mind
all night long
hey yeah thank you for bringing me up to
date on the Roseann situation just
kidding what is the opposite of thank
you I don't know what well I don't know
what to bring up because like I don't
care about sports and but like that wow
man it's this is day two when we're
recording this of of the world being
like wow this this whole thing is
actually happening right now that this
is a this is a situation that we're
inside of and also that Russian
journalist who or Ukrainian journalist
didn't get killed by the Russian
government he didn't eat just was said
so and I don't I can't follow that I
cannot do using recommend not having a
Twitter enough because you get a
completely different set of news like
you don't get that like breaking it's
happening now news instead you get sort
of like summaries of the news provided
hours later once the news has broken so
while you're busy like breaking the news
I'm just in my garden waiting for the
next day when I will find out from the
Wall Street Journal in The New York
Times and The Economist what the news
was yeah it's sort of amazing to think
about how people used to live in a world
where you had to wait to the next day to
find out what news was is that's not new
it's the old let's get to some questions
from our listeners this first question
comes from Scott who writes dear John
and Hank some cows live in pastures
others live in beautiful diverse
landscapes with breathtaking ocean views
do these latter cows enjoy the view
Great Scott that's good one that's good
they they they must but also why haven't
we converted that land to apartments yet
people need houses John well the cows do
not appreciate beautiful views first off
that's the true answer I don't know
that's true I think I think that they
appreciate a diverse variety of things
to look at I do I really do and I don't
I don't have any objective scientific
basis for that but I think that all
organisms
have innate curiosity because that is
how you learn things and I think that a
more diverse environment is all like
almost always better for an animal even
an animal that has been bread and bread
and bread and bread to be happy or at
least satisfied in any situation I don't
disagree with that I just think that
like looking at it the ocean isn't the
most interesting view if you're a cow
right okay I think that like humans like
beaches but that doesn't mean that cows
like beaches I think what cows like
looking at is a field of like tall
flowing grass and they're just like look
at all that I really yeah I officially
now want to read watership down but with
cows like right now yes baby I would I
would totally totally ingest that
content except that it would have a very
sad ending well
have you read watership down it's got
it's got some sad parts it turns out
very sad parts very very sad parts
almost nothing but sad parts oh it's
very adventurous though and I want to
know what the cows are thinking John put
me inside of that in between those those
just lifeless looking beady eyes that
seem that contain nothing I want to know
what's going on in there do you know
that cows are one of many mammals that
could not survive without the bacteria
that colonized them oh of course
oh man cows would be totally over
immediately if it weren't for the
bacteria that colonized them but I'm
also one of those John did you know that
there are some species of bug there are
bugs that have bacteria in their
stomachs that allow them to survive
sometimes a funfun fungi yeast and
that's great
yeah that's so it's not just mammals
like like these bugs that eat eat wood
basically but bugs can't digest wood but
fungi can because fungi can digest
anything they're amazing yeah no I mean
it is crazy how dependent life is upon
life how that is very true John which is
why we should be looking out for all of
the life
and saying hey you life I forgot to not
kill you I'm so sorry
mmm I don't think we should look out for
all life equally I don't haven't agree
with that at all not even a little bit I
agree I agree with you
wait globe man we got to make sure to
protect all the mosquitoes because how
old's our people gonna get malaria
occasionally somebody will say to me
Hank all life is supposed to be helpful
to to the world but what's the purpose
of ticks and I was like I don't know
where you initial premise came from
right life is not like it isn't that
every life be every life is necessary
for it all to work no ticks can be over
immediately and everyone would be fine
yeah no let's let's get rid of ticks and
mosquitoes and just see what happens
maybe things will be worse but probably
not the next question comes from Kate
who asks dear Hank and John greetings
I'm Kay I love your podcasts I just
watched Jon's FIFA video about the
Alaska adaptation Congrats John and John
talked about signing a contract which is
very interesting for me because I have
currently in my hand a contract paper
that made me question a very important
thing for my future I'm 20 I dropped out
of college early because of a traffic
accident last February and I have a
passion in writing horror comics my
comments called the librarian and people
can read it for free on CIA y ou comm
she goes on to say that the comic has
been doing very well and there's like a
mobile game and animated web series
maybe even a movie and then says what I
realize I never once try to haggle any
of these contracts I just accept them as
is talking about money profits and
business is scary for me I feel like a
little girl lost in a tsunami of adults
and big companies what should I do so I
can handle this better for my future
contracts or is it actually just OK to
trust these people and have them pick
the prices for me any kind of advice and
opinions appreciate it wholeheartedly
thank you for reading this I hope I
could be as kind as you to when I'm
older okay that's very sweet that you
think they were nice John can agents
right that's the answer
agents yeah okay you need to get an
agent and any and if you're bringing in
income a lot of agents will be happy to
work with you like if you're
webcomic is generating any money at all
agents will be happy to take 10% of that
money and they are worth it at least a
good agent is because they can protect
your interests and I think if I'd had a
different agent when I signed up Looking
for Alaska Deal the rights wouldn't have
been sold forever and ever - paramount
now in the end that has turned out okay
because I am really excited about the
Hulu adaptation that Josh Schwartz and
Stephanie Savage are doing and I think
it's gonna be great but it has been a
very long 13 years since I sold the
rights and it has not always been fun
and a big part of the reason it hasn't
been fun is because in the process I did
not retain any control at all in any way
and that's been frustrating at times
because stuff has happened that I didn't
like or that I would you know that I
wouldn't have done and people especially
like people in the world outside of you
know the little pond of publishing don't
necessarily understand that the rights
that authors have and don't have are the
ones they retain and don't retain and
how that stuff can depend on who your
agent is right whatnot so yeah I just
think you need to have somebody who is
on your team and who has your best
interest at heart and who is an expert
in this stuff because otherwise the
negotiation just isn't going to be fair
right it's just never gonna be fair the
thing that I didn't realize going into
this is that it's not just like about
the number like the your agent is
looking at the thing and saying like
like this isn't enough money but it's
also about a thousand other things so
there's the amount of money you get paid
there's the amount of time the like
there's different ways that the like the
intellectual property can be used and
those are all different categories and
there's like how the money is paid out
this stuff you don't want to care about
I don't want to think about this stuff
and so I have to have an expert person
who knows what is like standard and what
to ask for and if they want one thing
what to not give them if they if you're
going to give them something else and
you don't want to be doing that
negotiation because one you're not a
lawyer and
soften our which is really nice and to
like you want to make stuff not worry
about all of this tsunami of adults and
big companies yeah I just think it's
really really hard not to get taken
advantage of if you don't have somebody
who's an expert who's on your team in
that process now some people do it some
people don't have agents and are very
successful and so our way is not the
only way but it's certainly the way
that's worked best for me also if
there's a tsunami of actual human bodies
that's very dangerous and you should get
away what could there be a tsunami of
that wouldn't be very dangerous like
it's hard to imagine any matter related
tsunami not a significant threat my
first thought was bowling pins and I
feel like that would be such a terrible
idea of like really painful nothing
worse than water not since you proposed
the dog named manhole have you had a
worse idea just a tsunami of like hippos
but maybe not big hippos baby hippos
miniature hippos just coming at you blah
blah blah that'd be bad too sure how'd
you suffocate oh under a pile of baby
hippos would have to be something even
like feathers that are leaves I feel
like if it's a tsunami and it's like
it's gonna get you to too much no we
should avoid tsunamis let's just try to
minimize the overall number of tsunamis
this next question comes from Jared who
writes Dear John and Hank I've been in a
real reading slump lately and everything
I try to start doesn't hold my interest
when I don't follow through with a
recommendation from a friend they often
get upset or offended that I didn't
finish it or give it a fair chance yeah
but life's too short to finish a book
you're not enjoying right I've seen Hank
tweet several times about the expanse
series by James sa Corey which I loved
and the Kingkiller Chronicle by Patrick
Rothfuss which are my very favorite
books I've decided maybe you are who I
should be getting my recommendations
from any other great suggestions to get
me back into reading again other than of
course your book an absolutely
remarkable thing which comes out on
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now he went to comma Jared
that's a joke that only Americans will
get people outside of America are gonna
be like what but Jared is a jewelry
chain in the United States and all the
commercials are like oh my god it went
to Jared it's a
it's a pretty sexist terrible biote
realistic it does give Jared a name
specific sign off which is great so it's
good it's got that going for it the
first thing I gotta say to you jared is
never be ashamed for liking the media
that you like it's okay to be like I
didn't I'm not into that thing it's
always good to expand your horizons try
out new stuff but if your friends want
you to like a kind of book that you
don't like that's okay and if you find
the kind of thing that you do like then
go for it and a there are lots of good
places to get recommendations based on
the stuff that you like I just read a
book that was you'll probably like very
much even though it will last you for a
total of two days because it's a
page-turner called dark matter by a
person whose name I can't remember
that's a great recommendation
have you read at John no it's by Blake
Crouch and is really it's it's you know
it's an adventure II page-turner book
and super fun sci-fi and I think that
you'll love it Jared I also can't
recommend cat Valenti's space opera
enough times which I feel like I've done
it a lot but I just like it so much
I'm gonna recommend children of blood
and bone to both Jared and you Hank I
thought it was great just really really
great big fantasy world full of
excitement
if you liked Kingkiller Chronicle z-- I
think you'll love it
it's really it's really really good and
only the first book in the series is out
so you can have that wonderful slash
terrible feeling of having to wait wait
wait wait wait for the next book also
Jared I'm gonna recommend my books I
don't know if you've read them but I
yeah you know my books especially
Turtles all the way down because it is
available only in hardcover and I'm not
above that Jared I'm not above trying to
squeeze out an extra dollar in 60 cents
from you
well at this point like does the amount
of money you make go down per book
as time goes on like when that goes to
different types of paperback I imagine
it does uh well you mean like do
mass-market paperbacks pay less than ya
know yeah they do usually but that said
the the big the big gap is between
hardcover and paperback so by those hard
covers thank you thank you so much for
doing that - I've got a garden to
maintain pay for those peas yeah you
know I'm paying 25 cents of pea right
now in terms of it turns the amount of
peas I'm getting per gallon of water
used so new pair of peas like if you buy
a hardcover of turtles all the way down
what that means for me is 11 peas it's
terrible which this next question comes
from John who asks dear Hank and John
are there any good billionaires
gentlemen goes on to describe a number
of billionaires some of whom are more
well known for their good and some who
are more well known for their bad but
but really I think we can just leave it
at that are there any good billionaires
so I I'm going to take a pretty
unpopular position on this one Hank
because I know that in our culture there
is nothing that people like to both
worship and hate more than billionaires
like in a way it feels like in this this
new Gilded Age just like the last Gilded
Age that billionaires have become their
own form of celebrity even though the
vast majority of billionaires aren't at
all famous the billionaires who are are
kind of wildly famous or famous beyond
all it's great it's it's weird we live
in a weird time for billionaires not
just well-known but but worshipped in a
way yeah but worshipped and then treated
by others as false idols yes it's almost
like you have to fall one place or the
other billionaires are good or
billionaires are evil instead of
billionaires or humans and they're
complicated and they're capable of doing
good things but I think it's very
difficult to become a billionaire
without
you know behaving in ways that mm-hmm
dot dot dot I think that the other thing
to to consider is that while a
billionaire of course I don't think that
ability any billionaire is is evil I
don't really believe in the idea of evil
when applied to people and that's a big
that's a big thing to say and not but I
do yeah so we should Jen and I will
disagree on that but III one of the
questions that I think about is like
whether the possibility of billionaires
is evil like the fact that it's
reasonable to have right level of but
that is the thing that I think is is the
problem I don't think it should be
possible for there to be billionaires
and yeah and it is it requires a sort of
incentives that don't make any sense
societally or individually like I don't
yeah
that I'll leave it at that yeah I
absolutely agree I think sometimes
people feel like billionaires are exempt
from social socio-economic political
pressures that somehow they've escaped
the systems that shape the rest of our
lives and I just don't think that's true
and I think there are things that are
evil about the system and billionaires
in many cases have benefited from those
systemic evils and that should trouble
them but I have also benefited from a
lot of those systemic evils and that
needs to trouble me ya know from talking
to you that it does oh it does I buy my
new book I've ever made I didn't like it
much the first time but I really didn't
care for it the second time is so often
the case this next question comes from
Andy who writes Dear John and Hank when
I do my laundry the lint filter always
fills up with every load I don't know
what kind of laundry you're doing there
Andy but it seems like you're going a
little hard but doesn't this mean that
clothes are shedding mass and should
eventually disappear are my clothes
gaining mass from another source so that
the net loss is zero or is this process
just so slow that I should be measuring
my clothes in geological time a and B
and C and D oh that's good and Andy
you're closer losing mass but they are
losing mass very slowly that's why when
you have a 35 year old t-shirt it feels
real real thin well and also wide
clothes brick I mean it you definitely
see this with with jeans I'm just like
where did my pants go these there was
wave and I thought I couldn't be
fascinating I don't know why I've never
seen anyone do this put some jeans in
the washing machine and then take up the
lint filter and weigh it and then take
out the pants and weigh them or and
after and find out how much pant you
lost every time like it's basically like
saying tell me how long before my pants
don't exist anymore and I should stop
watching my pants you know they say John
that you shouldn't wash jeans this is
the new thing you should never wash your
jeans and that's just a headline that I
read and I know nothing else about that
because that's how the internet works
now it's gonna say welcome to 2018
Internet where you can read a headline
and be an expert never wash your jeans
again stop married stop doing that
this next question comes from Rachel
wood writes Dear John and Hank I'm in my
grandmother's house which is decorated
with all manner of lovely needle points
and hook rugs however there is one
hanging in the main floor bathroom of a
large black cat with angry yellow eyes
that stare into the depths of your heart
and steal your soul those eyes are the
only bright spots in a black tiled
bathroom with a black toilet and black
counters furthermore it is positioned
above the toilet facing the sink so if I
want to pee or wash my hands I have to
turn my back on the creepy cat risking
my very life I can keep an eye on it in
the mirror but sometimes that's even
worse the other bathrooms are occupied
and I really have to pee what should I
do
semper OB subbu be Rachel by the way
that means always wear
under where it's a fun it's not how the
Romans would have said it but you get it
I get it Rachel your grandmother is a
Satanist or she's just really into the
occult
she's definitely really into the occult
but she only expresses it in one
bathroom uh well yeah also but there's
ways to handle this I I mean one like
first support your grandmother and
whatever her beliefs are like absolutely
believe different things but also it's
okay while you're in a situation Wits
private private situation to just take
something move it and then put it back
when you leave you don't have to you can
touch the creepy cat towel yeah it's not
a towel it's a rug I mean a needlepoint
it's a what I don't know my nouns
it's a needlepoint but thought of
Rachel's grandmother carefully needle
pointing this evil black cat to put in
her black bathroom that is the main
bathroom guests of the house use is just
so magnificent and I want to
congratulate Rachel's grandmother on
being so successfully creepy like how
wonderful is it that there's a goth
grandma in the world I think it's good
news Rachel I think you should embrace
your goth grandma and be grateful for
her now the question is would it be
better to have the creepy cat like when
you're peeing facing like looking at you
from behind and you don't know what it's
doing or is it worse when you if you
took pee and stare into the eyes of its
way worse to stare into the eyes
definitely worse I don't know it's
always waiting when you're not looking
is also very scary because you don't
know what it's doing back there
Rachel is there any way you can draw a
smiley face on the cat because I feel
like a yellow eyed black cat is super
intimidating until you draw like a
clownish smiley face on it and then it's
just not a big deal is it maybe that
like having something behind you scaring
you helps you pee like maybe your
grandmother's a little bit a little bit
like blocked in the bladder sure needs
needs the fear to ingest higher the
grandma pee brilliant
Hank you've solved it you've solved it
again I mean just call him Perry Mason
ladies and gentlemen Perry Mason no no
see that is everybody knows who Perry
Mason is Hank I mean that show didn't go
off the air until like 1974 oh gosh
Perry Mason I got a Google it I got
ahold of it it went off the air in 1966
oh Jesus it's worse than I thought all
right just call him Columbo eighties and
gentleman call him Columbo that's better
but still bad what's the guy from CSI
just call them Law & Order SVU just call
them that guy from CSI Miami with the
sunglasses David Brancaccio David Brown
David that was the guy who came up when
I said the guy from CCS is Warrick brown
who's he David Caruso it's David Caruso
isn't it oh my god I if it's David
Caruso I feel like I should win some
kind of honorary Oscar David Correia
David Caruso bestowed upon John Green
put those sunglasses on you stumbled
forth into the unknown of your own mind
and found a place that was correct Wow
I'm very pleased with myself for
remembering who David Caruso was anyway
I hope that David Caruso wherever he is
is well it's nice of you John I really
like how you're always thinking about
other people this question comes from
Katie who asks dear Hank and John is it
dishonest to not tell Internet celebs
that I know who they are if I find
myself in a casual conversation with
them eg we sat next to each other at the
theater and are chatting like strangers
even though I know weird facts about
them and honestly quite a lot about the
life they share publicly please answer
so I have one fewer thing to keep me
awake at night Katie this is sleepy
emoji I I've definitely been in the
situation where I've met people several
times before I found out that they knew
who I am and I don't feel weird about
that I can usually tell or at least I
can I think I can usually tell oh I've
been wrong
you ever been wrong because that's the
worst oh yeah it's super embarrassing to
be wrong there was one time I might have
told the story on the pod before where
my buddy Chris and I were at the airport
and he checked out right in front of me
and then I was checking out and the
young woman behind the counter was super
nervous and excited and I she was like
can I ask you a question and I was like
yeah you know yeah I am and she said was
that Vince Vaughn you know I mean he
looks exactly like Vince Vaughn
I used to say he told that stir in the
pub before I forgotten it so you're good
yeah yep yep and I was like oh no that
wasn't Vince Vaughn I've actually been
on the other side of this experience
I'd valeted my car and I was waiting for
the car to come back and also waiting
next to me was actually the guy who won
the Indy 500 over the weekend willpower
that's his real name and he's one of my
favorite drivers he's an incredibly
talented driver and a wonderful person
does a ton of work in the community and
it's just a lovely lovely guy and I was
like oh my god that's willpower oh my
god oh my god oh my god and then I just
like tried to talk as normally as I
could to him and we had a pretty fairly
normal conversation he actually spoke to
me first otherwise I wouldn't have
spoken to him we had a fairly normal
conversation and then the valet pulled
up my Chevy Volt and willpower said you
know I am also a Chevrolet driver I said
I know I know I know you're a chevrolet
driver I know you drive the number
twelve Penske I also have a Chevrolet it
goes 237 miles an hour it is like well
mine has an electric battery with a
gasoline generator backup willpower I do
think that it's fine to pretend or just
to act like the person you're talking to
is a normal person and try to talk to
them in a way as poss the only the only
way that this gets weird is is if the
relationship persists and goes I I had a
friend who was dating a girl
or a year before he found out that she
was a fan of his for a year before they
met and that's a little weird
yeah I'd bring it up before your
one-year anniversary yeah it's like oh
that seems like a big lie that we've
been living with haven't we
that's it like a medium sized lie but
you know one a big enough lie a big
enough lie that maybe it shouldn't have
been there in the first place this next
question comes from Zachariah who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a senior in high
school and I've recently found myself in
a sticky situation or rather an unsticky
situation oh I just purchased it what's
that I said oh it's lubricated the
situation I mean I don't think that was
your phrase of the week but I kind of
hope that it was I recently purchased a
toaster from a nearby goodwill and went
on a cute random toast date with my
crush oh yeah wait does this person have
a crush on their toaster no no no no no
notice the brought that brought a person
along their date I don't know exactly
what that is but I'm excited to find out
more we got to the park and put the
bread in and had homemade orange
marmalade at the ready but the toaster
did not work and we had to go into the
evening toast deprived and none of my
special homemade marmalade was enjoyed
right right because it's the part where
there pause yeah Zecharia I'm just gonna
stop you right there
you can't take a toaster to the park and
get mad that the toaster doesn't work
because toasters require electricity and
you're in a park and that is the issue
and I have solved the problem most of
the parts I've ever been to don't have
plugs it's just like a thing they don't
have but sometimes maybe sometimes they
do when like when do you ever like walk
up to a tree in a park and you're like
huh if there's an outlet here oh there
is an outlet amazing picnic pavilion
yeah
where they're like you can rent out this
picnic pavilion if you would like to
have your son or daughter's birthday
party here and there's there's a
guerrilla area but maybe sometimes the
place to plug in your stereo I have seen
the grill area and I've seen the picnic
area and I can picture all of it and
where are the plugs you having a
battery-powered stereo I think it's
possible
hold on I'm gonna Google battery-powered
toaster to see if a such a thing
it does oh my god it does
I can't why not you got to go to Ali you
got to go to Ali Baba calm and this
thing takes 23 batteries oh no you have
to put it it doesn't recharge I was just
thinking that kind of your Chevy Volt is
a battery powered toaster yeah yeah yeah
hey hey you back off right there my
Chevy Volt is a magnificent magnificent
car
it's a amazing piece of engineering I
wish I had already here's a battery
powered toaster that toasts one slice
and costs 56 dollars on Amazon frankly
frankly Zechariah I think you got an
incredibly good deal on your dollar and
60 toaster that doesn't work in the park
bright I think I think you should just
be happy I think that you should just be
happy no matter what if that's an option
but also I think that you should be
happy that you're the kind of person who
goes on a toast date with your crush
because that feels like the kind of like
perspective that that comes from is also
the kind of perspective that's gonna
lead to just a really great life I agree
Hank and it reminds me that today's
podcast is brought to you by toaster
dates toaster dates yesterday you want
to be near electricity this podcast is
also brought to you by John's Pease
John's peas they're really the same as
other piece quarter apiece and of course
today's podcast is also brought to you
by David Caruso David Caruso remember ah
yeah Perry Mason remember
and finally this podcast is brought to
you by disappearing pants just put them
in the dryer turn the dryer on to
infinity open it after infinity has
happened no more pants isn't that always
true if you wait an infinite amount of
time yeah that's true yeah definitely if
you wait infinity all pants will be gone
we also have a real sponsor today it's
simple contact simple contacts is a very
simple way to get contacts it's a pretty
straightforward business you can get $30
off your contacts at simple contacts
komm slash Dear John or by entering the
code Dear John at checkout dear Hank
will also work now John you and I we
don't wear contacts indeed I feel like
at this point if I take my glasses off
people like stagger backward away from
me amazed that they're not in fact part
of my face like I have the Clark Kent
Superman thing built in I am basically
wearing a mask if I take my glasses off
but I know that some people like contact
lenses and I know that they are a
helpful and good thing to have but also
apparently can be kind of a pain in the
butt but I don't know anything about
this so I decided to read a review from
a simple contacts user does that make
sense John absolutely this review is
come the love air is the person's screen
name I was another skeptical customer
but immediately felt good about my
choice to use this app when I received a
text next day to confirming my order and
letting me know that the doctor would
review my exam within 24 hours I
reminded them that I chose one-day
shipping because I desperately needed my
contacts before a trip and they kept me
updated on the status of my exam and
contacts they told me that I should
receive my contact lenses when I needed
they told me that I should receive my
lenses by the time I needed them and
offered to refund my shipping if it got
there later than expected well I got
them the next day and I'm incredibly
satisfied with the entire experience so
yeah simple contacts will check to see
if your prescription has changed with a
test on your phone that takes five
minutes to take and have a doctor review
the results now of course this is not a
replacement for your periodic I health
exam which you have to do because you
you know you want to know if you have
glaucoma early on because that'll make
your life much better but if you want to
get $30 off your contacts you can go to
simple contacts comm / to your Hank or
use dear Hank checkout thanks simple
contacts indeed thank you very much
Hank before we get to the all-important
news from Mars into AFC Wimbledon I want
to ask you a few more questions
beginning with this question from Graham
mm-hmm Dear John and Hank for a birthday
gift my girlfriend got herself and I
meet-and-greet tickets to see my
all-time favorite band blink-182 I'm
super excited to go in all but since I
knew I was going all I can think of is
the old adage never meet your heroes to
call the guys from Lincoln
- my heroes is an understatement I worry
there's a truth to the saying and that
somehow I'll leave disappointed even
though it'll just be a quick hello and
have them sign an album or whatever
I'm sure I'm worrying about nothing and
that I'll leave with an awesome
experience how is meeting people you've
admired played-out bone Appetit gram and
cheese gram and cheese it's the things I
never get it until you say it out loud
and now I also didn't get that one until
I said it out loud it's good it's not
sure is that your phrase of the week
John Graham and cheese cuz it's a good
one I just know it yes well Graham would
have really helped you there that was so
and my experience I I've not I've had
some experiences where the people I've
seen but to be clear I've had a lot of
experience where I've met people that
I've like been a big fan of very lucky
in that regard
and almost never have I been like
disappointed by the experience I I think
that if like to some extent this don't
meet your heroes thing is a little bit
like might be better said as don't
idolize people that way because they are
just people right if you're disappointed
it may be because they're jerks it will
more likely be because they're people
and they might be tired and they might
be concerned about how long the line is
and they might be concerned about how
many hours until the show and so they're
there their mind might be on on other
stuff and that might be a bummer
now hopefully it'll be a quick
interaction and they'll be present and
you'll be present and you'll feel really
good about the opportunity and the and
and it'll feel awesome but I don't think
that always happens but I also don't
think it's anybody's fault that it
doesn't always happen like for a long
time I stopped wanting to do any
signings because I felt like I was
disappointing almost everyone in the
signing line by not being as present as
I wanted to be because of my mental
health stuff and just I just couldn't
like be there until I was like maybe
it's better not it's easy to get into
your own head about that and so the
moment you start like looking at the
person and being like am i satisfying
that that your expectations of this
experience you're like you never know
and so I'm like you kind of like
suddenly start to feel like every person
is just like I'm not
like you need to give me a five star
rating here because I don't know if this
is going well like how am I supposed to
do this am I supposed to make like a fun
and unique joke for every person because
I can't I do it I want the people like
the thing that I'm trying to say is like
I appreciate you and they're trying to
say I appreciate you and that is from my
experience like that's what up really
we're trying to get out of a meet and
greet is to like have that experience
where everything I do is reliant upon
people who support our content and and
if they want to say that they you know
have like have been had good experiences
because of the stuff that I've made I
want to tell them that I have had good
experiences because they like the stuff
that I've made and just that that moment
of mutual appreciation is the thing that
I try and get out of it instead of being
like am I supposed to be like make this
the most memorable amazing experience of
this person's life no we're just trying
to say we like each other yeah I can't
really do that very effectively I feel
like but the guys have blink-182 have
been added a lot longer so I feel better
about their ability to get it done gram
than I feel about my own ability so
don't ever meet me but I wouldn't worry
too much about
I mean I'm blink-182 we've got a
question here that comes from poppy who
asks dear Hank and John last year I was
diagnosed with cancer which has meant a
lot of hospital stays and a lot of being
around nurses and doctors
I'm thankfully fine and in remission now
but I still go to see the doctor fairly
often to make sure everything's going to
plan whenever I see doctors the first
thing they ask is how I am and as an
extremely awkward person I find this
question really difficult to respond to
every time are they asking me as a
doctor how my health has been or whether
like life at uni is going particularly
well am I meant to ask them how they are
- what are the social rules around
doctor/patient small talk I hope you can
provide a new some advice so that my
next appointment is a little less
stressful poppy so John you walk to the
doctor and the doctor is like how you do
and John what do you say I say fine
except for symptom so that we can get
right to the point because I don't think
that they're in
the room to become my friend and I
certainly have not gone to the doctor to
have a social engagement I've gone to
the doctor because I have a health
concern or because it's a check-up or
whatever and so I think you know even if
you have I I guess if you have a
long-term relationship with your doctor
you know you you might talk about other
things like for instance when Sarah was
pregnant our doctor who delivered the
babies you know we got to know that
doctor much better than we get to know
most doctors and so that's a little bit
different and it may be because you've
had a long-term relationship with with
these people and because you know
they've cared for you through treatment
for cancer and everything that it's
appropriate to you know answer by saying
that you're doing really well at
university that probably makes them
super happy to hear but also if you've
got a concern
I'd say lead with it right yeah I live
in a small town so I like see my doctor
sometimes at this store or a restaurant
or somesuch and so there's some
expectation that like we're going to
have a relationship that is beyond just
like I have a bad toe problem please
help I don't have any bad toe problems
I'm I knew my mom listen to the podcast
and so she's gonna call me and be like
what's wrong with your toe and so I just
want to make sure that we're explicit
about that this is a huge relief but
yeah I think that in general that's that
is small talk and it's okay to be like
good you schools great and and I've been
feeling XYZ and you know that that is a
fine amount of small talk but are you
supposed to ask them how they're doing
they're probably not gonna tell you any
of their symptoms and be like yeah well
I've got this chronic hemorrhoid that's
no fun that doesn't seem like a very
doctory thing to do but is also fine to
ask them how they're doing and they will
probably say boy this this uh rain sure
is a lot now on to doctor things yeah
there's a part of me that wonders what
people who live in extremely consistent
climates even talk about like if you
live in Los Angeles
what is the casual conversation about
like III
was 72° and beautiful again today that's
the reason I couldn't bear to live in a
place like that because the weather is
essentially the only thing I talk about
to strangers and if I didn't have that
if I wasn't able to say like oh it's a
hot one today
III think I couldn't I couldn't I I just
couldn't handle it man I could not
handle social engagements how about
those Kings oh god I can't do that I
can't do that partly because I'm just
not interested like nobody cares about
the sports that I care about like nobody
cares how the AFC Wimbledon did this
weekend in Indianapolis so it just
doesn't work for me but we're getting
ahead of ourselves
we don't want to get to the news from
AFC Wimbledon until the last possible
moment because it isn't great what about
what about if you're at a grocery store
this is a thing that happens in Missoula
because it's this type of place and
they've been somebody comments on the
items in your cart and I'm just like no
no like this like I'm super into
small-town living but I feel like it's a
violation of privacy to even look into
there and see what I'm going to put into
my body I don't want you to know that
totally totally yeah I don't need you to
see the three jars of French onion dip
okay I don't need you to know about that
right like you're sometimes I'll be in
line at the grocery store and I'll put
down like three things of lime Tostitos
and the person behind me will say
somebody's having a party and I'll be
like first off don't judge me
second nope it's just yeah just for me
man no it's just that I don't want to
compact at the grocery store for seven
days two days I eat a bag of tostitos
yeah and then on the seventh day I rest
your gardening fuel John you need
something to pump it up for your where
you're digging and watering and pulling
peas off plants yes really all the peas
you got that was all the peas I got I
mean actually I done another pea harvest
a few days earlier in which I got 13
piece it might have been closer to like
18 cents of pea I'm not
totally positive but it's not a great
return on investment I am enjoying
myself though Hank let's continue with
the gardening theme by answering this
question from Paige who writes dear John
and Hank I understand how ridiculous
this sounds but I feel I have nowhere
left to turn I'm very Pro gardening in
concept it can be relaxing and rewarding
plus you get food out if it not if
you're me I even took a beginning
gardening class at my college because it
counted as a PE credit I love it it's
brilliant Paige also you know PE credits
at College what's happening I know we
live in a different time
there's no Colombo on the air etc my
problem is that every time I buy plants
to nurture and love I feel like I'm not
gardening as much as watching my new
friends dah oh now I live in the middle
of Texas which is consistently in
drought and 107 degrees I don't
completely blame myself for my failure
but now every time I buy a plant I get
deep anxiety about it seemingly
inevitable death there's nothing
seemingly about its inevitable death
page should I give up on my dreams every
new chapter starts with a new page nice
page you got to understand that things
die it is the nature of things to die
your job is to keep them alive as long
as possible and hopefully get 11 peas
out of them also there's got to be
plants that grow in that weather I mean
there's you first as long as you got
water because that's what plants need
it's the plants crave you need water and
sunlight there are some plants that are
not gonna do well in 107 degrees but
there's got to be some that will and see
what you got to go do is go to like
Central Texas gardening calm which I'm
not even kidding is a website and you
find out about the kinds of gardening
that it best is best done in 107 degrees
you're not gonna grow the same things we
grow here in Montana but you're gonna
have a much longer growing season so
that's good yeah the thing I'd say is
that you got to give yourself permission
not to be an expert at first oh so don't
get bummed out when some of your plants
die because you're learning how to grow
plants and in the long run
plants overall are going to be grateful
that you've put in that time even if in
the short run it kills a few plants at
least that's what I'm trying to tell
myself because I'm a very novice
gardener
I've definitely killed some plants
already I also feel like it's much
easier to feel like you're taking credit
for a plant dying like if like I did
that than it is taking credit for them
like flourishing because it kind of
feels like they did that all I do is
like I just gave them the things that
they needed and they made themselves
into delicious tomatoes and artichokes
and and and bulbous onions so you you
you uh that's the thing that I find most
magical about gardening is that it's
sort of like I feel like I'm involved
but I'm only sort of this this this like
helping hand and then suddenly this tiny
tiny little speck of nothing has turned
into something that I've only ever seen
at the grocery store before it's very
weird to watch a carrot happen though I
mean you actually don't watch it it
mostly happens underground but yeah I
agree with you it is the magic like
suddenly you're like well this this
thing has grown up and like if the day
arrives and you yank it out and you're
like there's a freaking carrot under the
ground what was it doing down there
ya know it is pretty magical I mean just
watching the tomatoes to turn from green
to red I'm like this how does this
happen man my mind is blown yeah
speaking of mind blown heck it's time to
move on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon would you like to go first
today yeah John it seems like you want
to save the news from AFC Wimbledon to
the last possible moment so let's talk
about this very cool paper that just
came out in the Journal of Geophysical
Research which I know is your favorite
favorite I'm a longtime subscriber
absolutely III of course knew that and
do you want to know the very good title
of this article 8 I do a field guide to
finding fossils on Mars that is a great
title like I would read that book and
the great news is John that the article
is available it's in the Creative
Commons so you can you can read it
yourself
it's 29 pages long and it has a number
of very good graphs figures pictures and
the idea of it is to say like ok so here
are the places where it is best and
easiest to find fossils on earth here's
how the earth fossil record works and
yes Mars is a cold barren wasteland as
you
I want to say but at some point it was
not
it's definitely was warm enough to have
liquid water and it does that liquid
water stood on the surface for a long
periods of time and those of course are
the places that people want to look for
fossils and we have to know good places
to look when we're gonna send these
scientific experiments like the Mars
2020 Rover two areas on Mars they have
not yet selected the site where that
Rover will be landing and and so yeah
the paper is looking at various rocks
and minerals on Mars that could be the
places where ancient life would be
preserved places where it was warmer and
wetter for long periods of time for I
think hundreds of millions of years and
and also applying like basically recent
research into how fossilisation happens
on earth and the best places for fossils
fossilisation on earth and thus where we
should go to look for fossils on Mars
and that's a JIT that's really good
story that's like basically yeah why not
look and for a long time I feel like
NASA has kind of not wanted to call that
their mission because it you know I
think when we when we launched a Viking
there was this idea that like I we don't
know we're gonna find and then we
arrived and it was like well this planet
is a very very large desert a very cold
large desert and we had a lot of hopes
and turns out they were dashed but but I
think people are getting more serious
about like actually you know looking to
see if there is a way to discover what
may have been happening on early wet
Mars especially now that we know that
early Mars was wet ya know I think it's
really cool I am excited too that's cool
I love that title yeah there are so few
good titles in academic journals so it's
always a pleasure to come across a field
guide to finding fossils on Mars well
the news from AFC Wimbledon Hank do you
remember when we did like those dance
classes and then we would have to go to
those ballroom dances when we were in
like seventh grade and do you remember
how there was a rule that the boys would
have to walk up to the girls and saying
like shall we dance or whatever and then
the rule was that the girls had to say
yes mm-hmm
you remember all that I do do you
remember how when that happened to me
like the girls said no they all
organized themselves to say no and it
was like devastating and I was like
cried a lot I don't I didn't remember
that that's very bad I'm sorry I did not
know about that everyone always said yes
to me because that was the rule well
Hank AFC Wimbledon walked up to Dean
parrot and said shall we dance I offered
him a new contract and he said no oh no
he said no Dean parrot arguably one of
Wimbledon's best players said no and
instead signed for Jillian hammer
Gillingham I could never remember if
it's a soft arrrggg vet
I know it's in the same league they're
in league one it's not like they're you
know up a level
oh come I'm sure that they're probably
offering a little more money I am a
little disappointed though I can't
pretend not to be disappointed meanwhile
Jimmy Abdul the French player who spent
the season at Wimbledon who also would
have been very useful next season in
Ligue 1 has also decided to move on to a
club in the fourth tier in his native
France so that means the big above Hank
I don't even know if Wimbledon we don't
have a lot of players is what it comes
down to we're going to have to do a
tremendous amount of recruitment to play
to play a game of soccer how many do you
need I am astonished that you do not
know the answer but I'm gonna get
thirteen eleven with the two subs see
that we have more than two subs with the
two subs that you you generally use
there you get three subs in a game but
you think you can put either five or
seven people on your bench so you need
18 to really minimum but you need more
than that because there will be injuries
and stuff so it's not great the
situation that we build in our
in is not great like we lost a bunch of
our best players last season but that's
easy and it looks like we're gonna lose
while Taylor we've just lost Dean paired
in jimmy abdul it looks like we're gonna
lose a big part of the kind of spine of
the club and then we've released four
players including George Frank ohm and
Barry Fuller who were really important
last season so I don't know man
I am definitely mmm I am nervous I I
tweeted today on my Sports Twitter which
is now my only Twitter which I can't
recommend highly enough I tweeted today
is it too soon to be hashtag concerned
because I feel hashtag concerned
well what if like what does they've see
what what the need do they need money is
that the problem I probably mmm well
yeah it would be great to have more
money but the issue is that when you're
a small ish club in terms of budget it's
really hard to sign players to
multi-year contracts mm-hm and that
means that they can you know leave on a
free at the end of each season so it's
just really hard and of course it was a
tough season I mean if you're a player
like that's a hard hard season to go
through to barely stay up to feel the
nerves of the crowd every Saturday for
the last 30 or so Saturday's that you're
playing like it's hard so oh yeah yeah I
don't know yeah I don't know either I
don't know what to do about your
situation John but they look like very
handsome men I'm looking at the the
roster right now yeah we've got some
lookers I mean in the league one a hot
table some people say that we're a
playoff team I was just looking just
looking at a picture of one of your
players and thinking that man looks
quite old to be a soccer player but he
is two years younger than me and this
one looks like he's maybe 16 yeah
there's some there's some actual
children uh and it looks like some of
them may be playing next year oh well
maybe these got oh they got a lot to
move up to do
we'll see Hank what did we learn this
week oh well we learned that you can be
an actual child and be a professional
football player we also learned that if
your grandma is goth lean into it
forgot that we learned that we learned
that there are battery-powered toasters
available at Alibaba
and also sometimes Amazon and also we
learned that if you run into Indy 500
winner and Chevy driver will power just
be cool
just be cool just be cool John make what
was your phrase of the week you're gonna
have to tell me what you think my phrase
of the week was that was it that was it
bad toe problems no that's it that's
good I'm glad that I threw that in there
because it certainly seems like what was
it it was miniature hippos which
happened very early on oh and who
donated it it was from Johannes thank
you Johannes for donating to the project
for awesome and John was yours I don't
have any idea
disappearing pants no it was actually
nope it was actually I must dance but I
misremembered it as shall we dance so my
bad it was donated by the pineapples of
solidarity a nerdfighter group yeah well
I do like I do like a good introductory
story John and I'm glad that the phrase
of the week is giving you an opportunity
to do those before on the lookout for
them you should be you should be but
anyway I'm sorry I messed up your phrase
of the week pineapples of solidarity I
think we also have a project for awesome
message someone donated the project for
awesome to get us to read this message
on the pod it's from Matt and Kate of
Southeast Michigan to their son Maxwell
and it's called a short poem on a fourth
birthday
Maxwell my light bright body spry
curious eyes mind open wide heart and
soul kind Maxwell my son my light when
the time is right you'll fly it has been
an absolute joy watching you grow learn
and explore we are immeasurably proud
and cannot wait to see how you
contribute to the world we love you
dearly mom and dad geez Matt and Katie
that is
that is so nice and happy birthday
Maxwell John thanks for podcasting with
me people out there and thank you for
listening and if you want to send his
questions you can do that at Hank and
John at gmail.com that is our email
address and we appreciate everybody to
send some questions because how else
would we do a podcast you can also reach
us on Twitter I'm Hank green and John is
sports with John now apparently this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
and Sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno who also runs our patreon
which if you go and donate there it will
help out scishow and crash course and
you'll get our weekly bad podcast this
week in Ryan's which we're about to go
record right now thank you everyone for
listening and as they say in our
hometown don't forget the awesome
[Music]